the goldilocks hold on  [Music]  that's so hot  harcourt is very type a she's very  serious you have to make the hard choice  when necessary she is not suffering any  fools see if you can get to a balcony on  the second floor and jump  [Music]  wow  she's somewhat of a lone wolf she starts  off with the mentality that she would be  better off if she just was working alone  all right that's enough and you are  sounding awful awesome phobic  she's so strong and so flawed at the  same time i call in sick all the time  and i'm lying i know you're lying i just  don't give a [ __ ]  she's just the most well-rounded person  that i've ever gotten to play not bad  huh not bad  [Music]